mit dem zug an die adria-küste
eine atemberaubende reise durch serbien
und montenegro
die fahrt eines lebens durch
wunderschöne landschaften
traumhaft mit steilen hängen
täglich eine überraschung
bedrohlichen flammen und erdrutschen
[Musik]
und als entschädigung
spektakuläre aussichten
so reist man durch serbien und
montenegro
[Musik]
die reise startet in der serbischen
hauptstadt belgrad und geht bis
nachbarin montenegro
die route führt über das majestätische
dynamische gebirge
quer durch eine region die noch vor
wenigen jahrzehnten von einem grausamen
bürgerkrieg erschüttert wurde
auf den zug ist immer verlass er
transportiert die menschen durch
schwieriges terrain bis zur adria küste
kurz nach 8 in belgrad serbien
express zugnummer 431 nachbar auf plus 1
ein bahnmitarbeiter checkt alles durch
die räder prüft er mit dem hammer
[Musik]
wenn man mit dem hammer draufhaut und
ein klares geräusch hört deutet das
darauf hin dass das rad in ordnung ist
und keine risse hat
alle räder klingen einwandfrei
lokführer sascha ranjid steht auf
position um die letzten bremstests zu
überwachen
wir testen die bremsen an jedem
einzelnen wagen
das ist wichtig für die sicherheit des
zugs besonders auf der heutigen strecke
da geht es steil rauf und runter
[Musik]
ich danke ihnen alles in ordnung
bremsen getestet bereit für die abfahrt
die fahrt beginnt am historischen
bahnhof top ski dr er wurde in den
frühen 1930 er jahren gebaut die
bahnhofshalle war einst der warteraum
für die gäste des königs von jugoslawien
vielleicht ein bisschen altmodisch genau
wie der preis die einfache fahrt kostet
nur 21 euro
[Musik]
es gibt keine online-tickets man muss
sich die karte direkt am schalter kaufen
dafür ist die reise wirklich
preisgünstig toll
da ist der zug fährt gleich los ich
steig schnell ein
fast überall im land gibt es
automatische weichen aber im bahnhof
topsy der wird noch selbst hand angelegt
eine altmodische methode aber sie
funktioniert nach wie vor
wahrlich kein luxuszug aber eigentlich
ganz nett kein schnickschnack dafür
zweckmäßig das ist mein abteil
unser lokführer ist seit 30 jahren auf
der strecke unterwegs und hat viel
erfahrung
eine der anspruchsvollsten bahnstrecken
europas aber man muss sich gut auskennen
welches tempo
frohsinn brücken und tunnel
tag eins der reise führt auf einer fast
300 kilometer langen strecke durch die
berge
erster stopp franetzki zeit für eine
runde mit dem berühmten museumszug der
satan bahn weiter geht's nach plo pauli
am nächsten tag über den atemberaubenden
malaria viadukt die höchste brücke
europas nachbar montenegro an der
adria-küste
insgesamt ein ganz schönes auf und ab
zunächst drauf auf knapp 800 meter durch
das dynamische gebirge
am zweiten tag sogar über die 1000 meter
marke
[Musik]
camilo speicher norwich kontrolliert und
verkauft die fahrkarten
fahrscheine bitte
aber das ist längst nicht alles
so bitte sehr genießen sie die fahrt
bei einer störung auf offener strecke
ist der schaffner dafür zuständig die
lokomotive zu lösen und die bremsen zu
checken
das ist wegen der vielen steigungen
besonders wichtig so gewährleisten wir
die sicherheit
trotzdem genießt er die reise
serbien ist schön für die strecke
braucht es eine starke lokomotive auf
der ersten etappe kommt der elektro
transporter sv 4 4 1 zum einsatz ein
arbeitspferd das schwere güter oder
personenzüge zuverlässig über die waage
bringt die lok ist 15 meter 47 lang vier
meter 65 hoch und drei meter 10 breit
gewicht stolze 80 tonnen
außerdem hat sie einige jahre auf dem
buckel und braucht viel
fingerspitzengefühl die
[Musik]
lok ist etwa 40 jahre alt also nicht die
modernste
sie ist nicht vollautomatisch das heißt
viele vorgänge müssen manuell
durchgeführt werden
die geschwindigkeit muss sich je nach
steigung kurve und zu gewicht anpassen
[Musik]
wir verlassen gerade belgrad eine sehr
große stadt es dauert also ein weilchen
bis wir da raus sind die waggons da
drüben sind voll mit graffiti das ist
hier ganz normal
[Musik]
an manchen bahnhöfen gibt es
jugendgruppen die sehr geschickt mit der
sprühflasche umgehen selbst wenn der zug
nur eine minute an hält
das reinigungsteam nimmt sich die
waggons ein bis zweimal im monat vor ein
harter job
wenn der lack 48 stunden getrocknet ist
ist es ziemlich schwierig ihn wieder
abzukriegen vor allem wenn es mehrere
schichten gibt
das sind künstler künstler auf ihre
eigene art
sie machen ihren job und wir unserem ein
ewiger kreislauf
[Musik]
mitreisende auf diesem trip slobodan
russisch er arbeitet seit 1992 bei der
bahn und hatte schon viele posten vom
verkehrsingenieur bis zum direktor was
macht diese strecke so besonders
zunächst einmal die landschaft die
strecke führt über fünf hohe berge nicht
einen sondern fünf von belgrad nachbar
der bau war eine große herausforderung
wie würden sie den aktuellen zustand der
gleise beschreiben dieser teil der
strecke ist komplett saniert alles ist
neu die geschwindigkeit 100 kilometer
pro stunde
die ersten 80 kilometer der strecke sind
mit neuen gleisen ausgestattet kosten
rund 70 millionen euro für mehr hat es
bislang nicht gereicht
im moment fahren wir auf einem abschnitt
der vor drei oder vier jahren repariert
wurde
deshalb können wir genauso schnell
fahren die nach der eröffnung im jahr
1976 das
wird nicht so bleiben
auf den älteren abgenutzten gleisen wird
der zug deutlich langsamer fahren und
länger brauchen
nach der eröffnung dauerte die fahrt
sieben stunden heute sind es zwölf
[Musik]
so geschmeidig wie jetzt geht es nicht
mehr lange voran
die strecke wird steiler brauer und
anstrengender
da hinten sind die schienen in einem
viel schlechteren zustand wir haben ein
konstantes gefälle von 16 grad und
müssen die ganze zeit bremsen
kurz hinter belgrad ist die strecke noch
angenehm flach
schauen sie sich diese wunderschöne
ebene an ganz anders als eben noch in
belgrad
dahinten tauchen schon die ersten berge
auf da fahren wir jetzt in
diesen bergen geht es nicht nur
landschaftlich hoch hinaus einige der
größten menschen der welt leben im
dynamischen gebirge
ich spreche eigentlich ja obwohl kommst
du aus serbien nein ich komme aus
montenegro ich habe nur in serbien
urlaub gemacht ich habe gehört dass
einige der größten menschen der welt aus
dieser gegend kommen
unsere regierung ist die zweitgrößte der
welt glaube ich wirklich deren
durchschnittsgröße beträgt 1 meter 98
du bist unverkennbar auch von hier es
stellt sich raus dass die fakten stimmen
ich bin nicht von hier
langsam geht es bergauf
die lok braucht mehr energie um den zug
zu ziehen wenn die steigung 15 16 oder
sogar 20 prozent beträgt das ist hier
der fall
dies ist eine elektrische lok sie
bezieht ihre energie überdrehte und
stromabnehmer auf und über dem zug
damit nichts schief geht wird alles
regelmäßig inspiziert
der stromabnehmer hat schieber mit einer
graphit beschichtung von etwa einem
zentimeter
sind sie abgenutzt müssen sie
ausgetauscht werden
diese beschichtung muss nicht ersetzt
werden also geht es weiter nach unten
zur brems inspektion
diese beiden müssen ausgetauscht werden
wir überprüfen ob die stärke der
bremsbeläge unter den zulässigen
grenzwerten liegt
benötigt werden sie aus
sicherheitsgründen ersetzt
geschieht das nicht kann der zug nicht
mehr richtig bremsen und könnte
entgleisen
nach gründlicher überprüfung geht die
reise weiter
die lok meister die steigungen mit
leichtigkeit
schon liegt der kamm des drenovak weg
hinter uns mit 500 metern die erste
große steigung
[Musik]
die steigung von 15 oder 16 prozent
haben wir geschafft jetzt geht es bergab
hier kann es gefährlich werden volle
konzentration ist gefragt
wir müssen immer wieder bremsen bei
mitte das tempolimit nicht überschreiten
alle 20 sekunden betätigt der lokführer
die sogenannte tod man einrichtung um zu
zeigen dass er bei der sache ist tut er
das nicht bleiben ihm nur fünf sekunden
sonst stoppt der zug gleichzeitig muss
er bremsen
wir dürfen nicht die ganze zeit bremsen
umsonst überhitzen die bremsen und
verlieren an leistung
so weit darf es nicht kommen sonst droht
eine katastrophe auf den strecken mit
starkem gefälle
einfahrt in den bahnhof von putziger
inputs eger ist ein kontrollzentrum dass
die strecke von kurz vor belgrad bis zur
grenze zum unter negro überwacht nicht
mehr ganz taufrisch aber voll
funktionsfähig wie überwachen 2 184
kilometern eisenbahnstrecke es gibt 26
bahnübergänge im nördlichen teil und
zwei im südlichen teil
zwei fahrdienstleiter und zwei zugführer
behalten 34 bahnhöfe im auge sie
überwachen 30 bis 40 züge gleichzeitig
unterstützt werden sie von
elektronischen geräten wie den
sogenannten ax zählern wenn der zug über
den achs zähler rollt werden die achsen
gezählt und die jeweiligen gleise als
befahren markiert
verlässt der zug den bahnhof passierte
er einen sensor dann einen weiteren
anhand der dafür benötigten zeit werden
richtung und geschwindigkeit des zuges
ermittelt
bei der einfahrt in den nächsten bahnhof
über fährt der zug zwei weitere sensoren
so weist die leitstelle dass sich der
zug nicht mehr auf dem streckenabschnitt
befindet das system dient dazu
zusammenstöße zu verhindern
nächster halt besitze eine stadt mit
über 50.000 einwohnern
zwischenzeitlich war sie nach dem
ehemaligen jugoslawischen staatschef
tito benannt der sich für den bau der
eisenbahn einsetzte
tieto weiter die strecke von belgrad
nachbar mit seinem berühmten blauen zug
ein
starts besucher fuhren damit wenn sie
nach jugoslawien kam die gäste wurden im
großen speisesaal empfangen sie tranken
aus feinstem porzellan auszeit gefällig
dafür gab es ein luxuriöses bad und
außerdem ein eigenes büro interessierte
können heute den zug in belgrad
besichtigen und wenn sie das nötige
kleingeld haben können sie ihn sogar
chartern
zurück zum balkan express
zeit für einen schichtwechsel
bitte warten sie einen moment wir sind
in musik hier wird das personal
ausgetauscht auch lokführer und
schaffner
wie gehts läuft alles den schöffen an
bleibt nur wenig zeit für den
informationsaustausch
ich muss ihm die aktuelle situation im
zug erklären ob alles in ordnung ist
seien teil der bahnstrecke ist der
schwierigere jetzt kommt der hügelige
balkan wie wir hier sagen wir fahren ein
bisschen langsamer als sie fahren
langsamer
der neue lokführer heißt wie drastisch
er hat hier schon viel erlebt
es vergeht kein tag
ohne irgendeine art von überraschung es
geht bergauf ins labor mittelgebirge
fast 800 meter über dem meeresspiegel
die größte gefahr geht von erdrutschen
aus sie können den zug sogar zum
entgleisen bringen vier bis fünf mal pro
jahr ist die strecke wegen erdrutschen
gesperrt
ein paar kilometer weiter arbeitet ein
team daran das zu verhindern
die stützmauern haben durch den
erdrutsch risse bekommen sie sind in
bewegung
der fels entlang dieses
streckenabschnitts besteht weitgehend
aus weichen kalkstein der über millionen
von jahren vom wasser abgetragen wurde
loses gestein und riesige höhlen sind
die folge keine gute basis für den bau
einer eisenbahn
füllen sie hier links noch ein bisschen
auf
dies ist ein einfacher aber effektiver
test um festzustellen ob sich die
felswand verschiebt wir bringen ein
stück glas an bewegt sich die wand
zerbricht es
zerbrochenes glas bedeutet dass die wand
verstärkt werden muss jeder erdrutsch
ist eine bedrohung er gefährdet sowohl
die stabilität der bahn als auch die
gleis geometrie der hang ist mit netzen
bedeckt sie sollen herabfallende trümmer
auffangen lockere felsen werden
identifiziert und beseitigt heute
entfernen wir die losen steine vom hang
dazu erstellen wir eine prioritätenliste
um festzustellen welche steine am
lockersten sitzen absichern bedeutet vor
allem harte körperliche arbeit ok ziehen
wirkt ein fels bedrohlich wird er
abgeschlagen und weggeräumt
das muss hier regelmäßig gemacht werden
[Musik]
der zug rattert immer noch durchs labor
gebirge
auf diese dramatische landschaft habe
ich mich wirklich gefreut hier gibt es
unglaubliche berge sie reichen bis in
die ferne die malerische szenerie
bedeutet aber auch dass es wirklich
schwer war gleise zu verlegen
eine eisenbahnstrecke zu bauen ist nie
einfach aber im hochgebirge ist es
besonders schwierig es gibt
unterschiedliche methoden eine riesige
steigung auf clevere weise zu überwinden
ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen wie
schwer es gewesen sein muss diese
strecke zu bauen
bis zum zielort bar in montenegro sind
es noch viele kilometer
zeit für einen zwischenstopp um eine der
größten sehenswürdigkeiten der reise zu
bewundern
ich steig hier aus weil das der
nächstgelegenen bahnhof zur berühmten
sack am bahn ist die nämlich jetzt
die fahrt beginnt in nicaragua das
bedeutet so viel wie nasser berg das
dorf liegt an den hängen von 3 bergen
mit drei flüssen von daher geht es den
berg sagan hinauf kein leichtes
unterfangen
[Musik]
bis zum gipfel sind es 300 meter
höhenunterschied
auf direktem wege wäre das vollkommen
unmöglich viel zu steil für einen zug
stattdessen schlängeln sich die gleise
in form einer acht die hänge hinauf
die entfernung zwischen den beiden
bahnhöfen beträgt nur dreieinhalb
kilometer die bahnarbeiter mussten aber
15 kilometer gleise verlegen
um den höhenunterschied zwischen den
beiden bahnhöfen zu überwinden war dass
die einzig mögliche lösung beim bau der
strecke
[Musik]
die bauarbeiten dauern von 1921 bis 1925
und täler und berge zu überwinden
errichten die ingenieure zehn brücken
und 22 tunnel
wir sind gerade raus aus einem tunnel
während der ganzen reise spielen tunnel
eine wichtige rolle für eine
eisenbahnstrecke durchs gebirge braucht
man viele tunnel
ursprünglich sollte die bahnlinie hier
mit einer anderen aus österreich ungarn
verbunden werden heute ist sie wegen der
atemberaubenden aussicht vor allem eine
touristenattraktion
jedes jahr steigen mehr als 80.000
menschen in diesem zug die fahrt führt
zu einer aussichtsplattform dort
erwartet die fahrgäste der sogenannte
liebes felsen das ist der liebes felsen
du legst deine hand auf den stein wünsch
dir was und lässt etwas kleingeld da
damit es in erfüllung geht der große ist
für die liebe und der kleine für den
spaß du musst dich nur entscheiden du
kannst die stadt auch tauschen willst
[Gelächter]
das stimmt ich genese jedenfalls die
fahrt mit der seilbahn
wir sind angekommen das war eine gute
abwechslung bevor die reise weitergeht
richtung adria küste
bald erwartet die passagiere an bord
eine weitere attraktion
ein tunnel der neun jahre lang gebaut
und 1970 eröffnet wurde
wir fahren jetzt in den zloty bord
online er ist sechs kilometer lang
das kleine licht da es der eingang zum
längsten tunnel in ganz serbien er wurde
durch kalksteinfelsen gegraben das
bedeutet dass der bau relativ einfach
war die instandhaltung dagegen ist wegen
des weichen gesteins ziemlich
problematisch
[Musik]
das poröse gestein ist alles andere als
eine ideale basis
deshalb wird der tunnel täglich
kontrolliert
da entstehen noch malicks
es tropft
aleksandra kojic inspiziert den tunnel
wenn es probleme gibt
kurzfristig wird hier nichts passieren
aber mit der zeit kann das wasser mit
den stromleitungen in berührung kommen
ein stromausfall wäre die folge was
wiederum den verkehr zum erliegen
berichtete
das flusswasser dringt durch die risse
aber auch die risse selbst könnten auf
ein größeres problem hindeuten
es kann sein dass sich die hügel bewegen
die risse in den wänden könnten zur
verengung des tunnels und zu einem
schweren unfall führen
noch muss der tunnel nicht geschlossen
werden aber die experten überlegen die
risse abzudichten und rohre einzubauen
durch die das wasser abfließt
der zug hatte in tunnel passiert und
nähert sich langsam der grenze
die reise geht hauptsächlich durch
serbien und montenegro aber für einen
kurzen moment durchqueren wir genau
jetzt bosnien herzegowina aber es ist
nur ein sehr kurzer abstecher
der bau der strecke begann 1952 und
endete
1976 bis 1989 gehörte sie zu jugoslawien
dann riss ein blutiger bürgerkrieg das
land auseinander
in den folgenden zwei jahrzehnten
spiegelt sich die instabilität der
region auch in den grenzen wieder
bis 2008 verschieben sie sich immer
wieder
[Musik]
trotz aller unruhe fährt der zug weiter
und befördert auf seiner zwölf stündigen
fahrt bis zu 400 personen durch das
umkämpfte land zumindest ein fahrgast
glaubt dass der zug heute zur
völkerverständigung beiträgt
der zug fährt durch drei länder es gab
hier im lauf der jahre eine ganze reihe
von kriegen und konflikten glauben sie
er bringt die menschen aus verschiedenen
ländern zusammen
sicher es ist eine lange reise
viele stunden in denen wir nicht
miteinander reden zusammen essen
geschichten erzählen die
ruhige art entspricht unserer kulturen
es ist besser
wer es langsamer kann auf diesem teil
der strecke in gemächlichem tempo die
schöne aussicht genießen
durch die bäume sieht man den namen er
begleitet uns eine ganze weile etwa eine
stunde lang seinen smaragdgrünen farbton
verdankt der fluss dem kalkstein regina
sich gräbt
der zug fährt auch an steilen felswänden
und einem alten kloster vorbei bis er
die grenze zu montenegro erreicht
dort wird er durchsucht
[Musik]
wir checken jeden hohlraum
die polizisten suchen nach schmuggelware
wie zigaretten aber auch nach blinden
passagieren
der raum ist so groß da können sich auch
leute verstecken
ausweise werden mit speziellen
lesegeräten überprüft
wir sind in montenegro und hier werde
ich übernachten der zug fährt weiter
nachbar wird aber im dunkeln ankommen
ich möchte die strecke bei tages nicht
erleben deshalb nehme ich morgen früh
den nächsten zug
teddy kann eine mütze schlaf gebrauchen
morgen geht es zum spektakulärsten ort
der strecke dem malaria viadukt noch ist
es dunkel am bahnhof biolopur hier an
der grenze zwischen serbien und
montenegro
hier wird die lokomotive gewechselt für
das vor uns liegende gebirge ist sie
besser geeignet
die elektro lok der baureihe 461 hat
sechs achsen damit ist sie in kurven im
vorteil
der schienen kontakt ist einfach besser
als bei vierachsigen loks die 461 hat
sechs zugmaschinen was der leistung von
etwa 7 nasca rennwagen entspricht zuerst
muss sie angeschlossen werden
der strom versorgt die elektrische
heizung in den waggons und
auch die klimaanlage
jetzt kommt der bremsen check auf der
hügeligen strecke entscheiden
funktionierende bremsen über leben und
tod alle bremsen sind einsatzbereit
für den härtesten abschnitt der strecke
sind zwei fahrer zuständig veteran lewe
milovan und jetzt noch die bremsbeläge
und der 24 jährige nicola prijovic
sozusagen der copilot bei
einer störung gibt der assistent per
telefon den standort weiter sein kollege
muss aus sicherheitsgründen in der lok
bleiben
der nächste tag beginnt mit dichtem
nebel die
sicht ist wirklich schlecht bei der
suppe da draußen prijovic ist seit drei
jahren dabei milovan hat acht jahre auf
dem buckel
ohne praxis und ich meine wirklich echte
praxis ist man kein guter lokführer
es gibt auch einen neuen schaffner dusko
savanovic er erklärt den schlafwagen
das ist zur sicherheit der passagiere
damit sie nicht runterfallen es gibt
sechs kollegen hier drin ja für sechs
passagiere
ein kurzer stopp im billa sicher gebirge
wo provinz das steuer übernimmt der
örtliche fahrdienstleiter erteilt den
zugführern die erlaubnis die nächste
rote ampel zu überfahren
das signal ist nämlich defekt
sie haben uns gesagt dass das signal
nicht funktioniert wir können bei rot
durch waren
es gibt sogar eine schriftliche
erlaubnis aber das problem könnte weiter
bestehen der zug muss noch ein paar
tunnel und brücken durchqueren bevor er
zum highlight der strecke gelangt
im moment sind wir in einem kurzen
tunnel dahinter liegt der malaria
viadukt ein architektonisches wunderwerk
[Musik]
der mann arica viadukt ist die höchste
eisenbahnbrücke europas sprichwörtlich
also einer der höhepunkte der reise
sehen sie sich das an
sie ist
198 meter hoch als sie 1973 fertig
gestellt wurde war sie die höchste
eisenbahnbrücke der welt mit knapp 500
metern ist sie auch die längste brücke
der strecke die aussicht ist wirklich
unglaublich manche kriegen allerdings
höhenangst
die bauarbeiten dauerten vier jahre
250 bauarbeiter schufteten rund um die
uhr der untergrund ist aus weichem
kalkstein die stützbalken mussten
besonders tief ins erdreich getrieben
werden kräne wurden in den pfeilern
aufgestellt damit wurde das baumaterial
nach oben gehievt beton wurde nach unten
gegossen um die stützen zu stabilisieren
der höchste pfeiler ist fast 140 meter
hoch länger als ein fußballfeld
[Musik]
diese brücke ist das symbol unserer
eisenbahn
[Musik]
wir sind über die brücke durch einen
tunnel um eine kurve und jetzt diese
unglaubliche aussicht seht euch das an
ohne die brücke geht hier nichts deshalb
wird sie ständig überwacht
[Musik]
nach jeder überfahrt machen wir eine
sichtprüfung
radici witt co ist auf den gleisen
sobald der zug durch ist er
und seine kollegen sind täglich hier
wenn wir etwas finden das den verkehr
beeinträchtigt wird der zug angehalten
heute unterzieht das team von vera
voyage die strecke einer zusätzlichen
prüfung wir sind heute hier um eine
sichtkontrolle des malaria viadukts
durchzuführen punkt eins der zustand der
gleise
mit diesem gelben gerät überprüfen wir
die geometrischen parameter der gleise
mein smartphone liefert mir in echtzeit
daten über die breite der gleise die
höhe sowie eventuelle abweichungen
bei starken verschiebungen könnte der
zug entgleisen und in die tiefe stürzen
die bedingungen sind zufriedenstellend
die verkehrssicherheit ist in keiner
weise beeinträchtigt
nachdem die bauarbeiten abgeschlossen
waren hinderten starke winde die züge an
der überfahrt eine extreme windböe hätte
den zug über die kante drücken können
deshalb wurde diese abschirmung als
windschutz errichtet hier sieht man was
ein sturm mit den schienen anrichten
würde wenn sie nicht richtig befestigt
werden
aber auch die züge verursachen schäden
beim bremsen entsteht reibung das kann
dazu führen dass die brückenkonstruktion
feuer fängt
das verbrannte holz sieht schlimm aus
und wird ersetzt aber es stellt keine
gefahr für die züge da die inspektion
wird rechtzeitig beendet
die bahnstrecke ist sicher für den
verkehr
die fahrt durch das dynamische gebirge
in montenegro geht weiter
[Musik]
was für eine aussicht
der zug nähert sich einem steilen abhang
als der lokführer anhält
wir müssen hier anhalten weil es rot ist
die einfache signale auf beiden seiten
funktionieren nicht die defekten signale
sind weiterhin ein problem juve muss die
leitstelle vom festnetz aus anrufen
er gibt alle details durch und fragte ob
wir hier stehen bleiben sollen weil zum
beispiel ein anderer zug durch kommt
[Musik]
alles gut wir können durchfahren
nächster halt bot die strecke geht steil
bergab durch einen tunnel und endet vor
einer felswand hier ereignete sich der
schlimmste unfall in der geschichte der
bahnstrecke von belgrad nachbar
am 23 januar 2006 fährt ein zug einen
steilen abhang hinunter als plötzlich
die bremsen versagen der zug entgleist
und stürzte ins tal
45 menschen sterben an die 200 werden
verletzt
die tante eines fahrgasts ist an diesem
tragischen tag im zug
sie hat zum glück überlebt aber es gab
viele tote es war grauenvoll sie
erzählte mir dass der zug gegen die
tunnelwand prallte und aus den schienen
sprang dabei sind viele menschen
umgekommen
die strecke ist wunderschön und zugleich
gefährlich
die lokführer müssen sich auf die
bremsen verlassen können sie werden mit
luft und elektrizität angetrieben
benutzen wir die elektro dynamische
bremse sie fällt aus wenn sie zu heiß
wird das hängt auch von der menge des
verwendeten stroms ab
die druckluft bremsen an den waggons com
jetzt auch ins spiel prijovic bremst mit
viel gefühl so stellt er sicher dass der
zug nicht schneller als 60 kilometer pro
stunde fährt
[Musik]
an dieser stelle hat sich vor ein paar
jahren die tragödie ereignet
genau hier
der kompressor fiel aus und so raste der
zug einfach bergab vollkommen ungebremst
wenn ich hier lang fahre muss ich jedes
mal daran denken
die tochter meiner grundschullehrerinnen
kam bei dem unfall ums leben
das motiviert mich während der arbeit
immer bei der sache zu sein
diese einstellung kommt beim älteren
kollegen gut an
[Musik]
ich bin sehr zufrieden nikola hat alle
regeln befolgt und alles richtig gemacht
nach bio geht es jetzt über podgorica
richtung baar die reise war nicht nur
landschaftlich beeindruckend beim
schaffner weckt sie erinnerungen
in dem fluss da unten habe ich gehandelt
die strecke von globuli nachbar gehört
zu den schönsten der welt
tolle aussicht genau gefällt es dir
teddy
ich war noch nie in montenegro und ich
bin wirklich überwältigt von der
landschaft ich wusste dass es hohe berge
gibt um schön ist aber so was habe ich
nicht erwartet das ist traumhaft
aber die schönheit ist in gefahr von
frühling bis herbst ist die region
anfällig für waldbrände
ich habe schon viele feuer gesehen
kleine und richtig richtig große
unglaublich wie aus dem nichts
[Musik]
bei waldbränden ist sofort ein
brandschutz team zur stelle
leute wir haben ein feuer neben den
gleisen die flammen sind riesig bitte
geht kein risiko ein
[Musik]
das ist ein wassertank er enthält 25.000
liter wasser damit löschen wir brände im
gelände und entlang den gleisen
der tank stammt zwar aus dem jahr 1940
ist aber gut in schuss
[Musik]
in den letzten 15 jahren gab es in
montenegro fast 70 waldbrände pro jahr
dieses team lösch bis zu 40 brände pro
jahr
[Musik]
das feuer kann der bahnlinie gefährlich
werden wenn es stromanlagen und
transformatoren entlang der gleise in
brand setzt
es bedroht auch die brücken was zum
stillstand des bahnverkehrs führen würde
das feuer ist schnell gelöscht
schließlich ist das hier nur eine übung
zurück im zug steht der junge lokführer
vor der nächsten herausforderung
hier gibt es eine menge kurven deshalb
gilt tempo 30 die strecke ist
unberechenbar überall felsen und steine
prijovic muss häufig bremsen auf dieser
strecke verschleißen die räder dreimal
schneller als irgendwo sonst in europa
der zug ist wirklich schwer da drückt
metall auf metall darunter leiden die
reeder sehr
okay leute heute ist diese lokomotive
dran
die räder werden am ende jedes monats
gewartet
menschenleben stehen auf dem spiel wie
verhindern tragödien mit dem in die
lokomotive im depot durchchecken
mit lasern und magneten wird der
durchmesser der räder gemessen
dann werden sie passgenau zu recht
geschlossen
wir schleifen je nach beschädigung skat
dauert die reparatur je nach abnutzung
zwischen zwei und sechs stunden danach
geht es zurück aufs gleis
der schwierigste teil der reise ist
geschafft
zeit für den nächsten stopp um einen
blick in geheimnisvolle höhlen zu werfen
wir sind in podgorica die hauptstadt von
montenegro hier gibt es über 10.000
hören ich bin gerade auf dem weg eine
der größten zu erkunden
[Musik]
hey wie gehts ich bin teddy hallo
willkommen in der liebherr höhle
das ist erstaunlich dass ist alles
kalkstein richtig genau dies ist eine
kalkstein höhle sie wurde von einem
fluss ausgehöhlt dem fluss zieht ihn er
ist heute nicht mehr da aber es gibt
noch unterirdische kanäle
diese topographie diese karstlandschaft
haben wir bis jetzt nur von oben gesehen
jetzt wissen wir wie es drinnen aussieht
wie weit geht es rein
das war eineinhalb kilometer wurden
bislang erforscht aber niemand weiß wie
tief die höhle wirklich ist
das ist toll stalaktiten kommt von oben
stalagmiten von unten richtig diese
werden orgeln genannt weil sie so
aussehen und weil die akustik hier am
besten ist
das ist erstaunlich wie nennt man das
das nennt man eine zunge sie besteht aus
kalziumkarbonat also kalt das wasser
bringt es zusammen mit anderen
mineralien mit und lagert es auf den
felsen ab so entstehen all diese
wunderbaren formationen stalaktiten und
stalagmiten
willkommen im heiligen gral wir sind
jetzt in einem anderen teil der liebherr
höhle dies ist der grösste stadt mit
hier unten
das ist unglaublich so was habe ich noch
nie gesehen
die einsteigen wir müssen los das war
wirklich cool jetzt kommt die letzte
etappe unserer reise alles klar danke du
es gar auf geht's
[Musik]
die strecke führt vorbei an einer
weiteren sehenswürdigkeit
das ist der skandal sei der größte see
in ganz südeuropa er liegt zwischen
montenegro und albanien
ein paradies für wildtiere hier gibt es
mehrere fischarten die nirgendwo sonst
auf der welt vorkommen
atemberaubend
jetzt sind es nur noch wenige kilometer
durch die berge von montenegro bis zum
zielort war
doch vorher geht es durch den längsten
tunnel des landes der 6,2 kilometer
lange so zinner tunnel
du hast deine sonnenbrille noch gar
nicht aufgesetzt wirklich enttäuschend
entschuldige vielmals
prijovic setzt die sonnenbrille auf
damit sich seine augen schneller an die
dunkelheit gewöhnen der tunnel wurde
1959 eröffnet
seitdem muss er ständig überwacht werden
denn das gestein ist bekannterweise
schwierig
regelmäßig werden proben entnommen
wie ist der fortschritt heute sehr gut
gegen welche probleme
keine probleme hier werden gesteins
proben genommen
das material nennt sich fliesst
wir haben hier schichten aus hartem und
weichem gestein
die proben belegen dass
links habe ich schluffstein der sehr
brüchig sein kann
in meiner rechten hand halte ich
sandstein sandstein ist meist eine gute
grundlage
die festen gesteinsschichten können sich
von den weichen schichten lösen
besonders anhängen wie diesem
das kann zu erdrutschen führen und die
gleise blockieren
kein idealer untergrund für bahngleise
wenn er mit wasser in berührung kommt
gerät leicht ins rutschen
das gestein kann die gleise so stark
verformen dass ein zug entgleisen könnte
sobald gefahrenzonen identifiziert sind
werden die entsprechenden gleise
ausgetauscht und felswände verstärkt
am ende des tunnels ist die endstation
bar in sicht
[Musik]
da ist sie also die adria-küste in
dieser gegend scheint die sonne an 270
tagen pro jahr die belohnung am ende der
reise es ist wunderschön und
ein attraktiver verkehrsknotenpunkt für
züge und fähren und nicht zuletzt gibt
es einen strand
kein wunder dass die strecke bei den
lokführern beliebt ist
als kind konnte ich mir nie vorstellen
lokführer zu werden aber jetzt will ich
nichts anderes machen
[Musik]
war die tat wirklich
ein abenteuer es hat spaß gemacht
er war großartig fantastisch er hat auch
einen tollen job gemacht
vielen dank es war sehr schön sie kennen
zu lernen
und ich hoffe sie kommen wieder mache
ich sehr gern danke vielmals sie waren
ein sehr guter passagieren dankeschön
eine unglaubliche reise mit
spektakulären ausblicken auf die
dynamischen alpen
aber vor allem hat mich beeindruckt dass
dieser zug zwei länder verbindet und die
menschen dieser regionen zusammen bringt